thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a royal
wild ride with Stevo it doesn't get more
Hollywood royalty than William Shatner
are you kidding me he's been in the
entertainment business for 80 years he's
92 years old are you kidding me oh my
God and if you think that this tour bus
that I'm traveling around the UK on
right now is futuristic wait till you
get a load of William Shatner's burial
plans for himself yeah dude very forward
thinking very candid and man I I just
wasn't prepared for how emotional I was
gonna get thinking about my own dad
being as old as he is talking to William
Shatner and just it's epic and this guy
is fascinated with my career
William Shatner's take on jackass is
absolutely hysterical you guys are gonna
love this one because I loved it way
more than I ever thought I could so
let's get into it
watch your head wash my head yeah okay
I've got I washed my head where am I
sitting
hello sweetheart hello
thank you
what an honor what a car yeah
okay so twist this to me
where and that's a camera there
a color of a preference uh blood
you know the color of blood yeah I bet
you do yeah
and we shouldn't get hot because we've
got this fancy new air conditioner
fantastic a whole tube the whole thing
um all right so let's not waste
anybody's time uh apologies for being a
little late
um would you like a water no I'm good
we'll Dive Right In yeah okay got nice
feet well thank you
you're not you don't have water
swelling yeah that's uh oh yeah oh yeah
yeah okay do you have swelling
sometimes yeah
ladies and gentlemen William Shatner
yeah it's me right here at a truck but
you can call in bill
that's the title
of the documentary that we're uh we had
a great success with at uh a big film
festival called South the southwest and
it's a lovely film and it's called Uh
you can call me Bill and the the the the
problem
which I know you will face from time to
time is a documentary has been about you
it's like a biographical film now you
got to go out and sell it like so let me
talk to you about me yeah and it's a an
anthematary I I can't stand it but uh I
have to so yes uh you can call me Bill
is a wonderful film yeah and and where
can people find it
um there's a rock under
um it's in the process of being put into
other festivals okay uh and uh people
are bidding on buying it okay where it
is and how to see it I don't know
exactly yet but keep that in mind
in addition to that uh there's a
documentary of a performance I gave at
Kennedy Center that's becoming a
documentary about it the performance and
the performance itself and things that
led up to the performance and an album
based on the same performance probably
called something like
um uh live at Kennedy Center yeah okay
and is that the album which will feature
the track I want to be a tree that's
correct that this is the most
fascinating thing we are Brethren okay
you and I
okay I think we've got many things in
common which make us very very entangled
and one of them that's that word
entangled is a very oh yeah precise no
no it's a good word oh is it okay yeah
no no that's a word that nature all of
us are in Tangled interwoven interwoven
yes right uh okay I
that feels so strongly and I've made
this public I've posted videos about it
that
cemeteries drive me absolutely insane
because
it's it's a cycle of life
so we're we're only temporarily
borrowing this physical matter this this
condensed energy for for a very brief
period of time and at the end of this
physical body for us to be so Jane uh is
it audacious vain just the hubris
obnoxious to take a plot of land to
permanently occupy and usually the most
valuable land because you got to dig
deep so you're getting through soft
porous Earth metal soil and occupying
and it's diminishing uh because people
are dying people don't stop dying right
right you know the saying
um an eye for an eye makes the whole
world blind
well I've submit that that cemeteries
make the whole world a cemetery
that's right yeah you you cease to exist
I was listening to a guy last night
being funny about somebody who committed
suicide and he used the phrase that he
they chose to take their own life and I
thought yeah you could choose that's
your life yeah you could choose where
you want to go and do and be you choose
usually someone chooses your education
for you but but but you you choose to do
what you want in life what you can and
do and I mean your life is your own it's
your own property right so you can
choose how you wish to end your life how
you want to go out
with pain and and remorse uh in a bed or
violently or giving your life to us a
cause it's yours to choose isn't it
Steve and I had a conversation that
we're both going to commit suicide by
dying of old age
I know and I'm in the throes
you know I I I'm I'm working on being
better with my conversational etiquette
but I have to interject here because I
rudely forgot to introduce my co-host hi
I'm Scott by the way Scott Randolph and
skinny Vinnie up in the front that's
great are you all on camera
then uh yeah it's all inclusive I get
carried away I get so excited that I
forget to well that's that's good and
and you follow through and you've
introduced everybody so it was like a
like an orchestra the beginning of a
musical so just quickly back to the
burials the idea that you are taking a
plot of land selfishly
permanently forever rendering it useless
for feeding people for housing people
for any kind of helpful productive thing
and on top of that once you have your
body buried there you've now made it
creepy no yeah so so if you believe in a
soul at life after death doesn't
interfere with that belief correct you
are you your body like every other body
that dies is taken over by fungi and you
know the nature reclaims you no matter
what you do so why not reclaim make that
have a voice in your Reclamation and I
chose a tree and uh and I wanted a
sequoia yeah oh you can choose the tree
well well you you could specify hey of
course you know put a a potted Palm on
my my burial site or a sequoia but you
need a certain altitude you got to be at
a certain the General Sherman up uh
exactly you got to be like four thousand
five thousand people uh so a redwood
okay California ready now how do you go
about doing this Are there specific
companies
you you would uh yes there are specific
companies and I haven't
I'm leaving it to the people who will
see me go to follow through since they
read your will yeah and they and they
got to buy a tombstone and find a plot
of land and get somebody that's bigger
oh you don't have to do any of that just
tell your loved ones
cremate me because I you have to
I'm not sure that you do put the good
the put the goodness
in place where the tree is going to grow
and plant a tree there's no law saying
you have to have a tombstone do you have
to buy that piece of property where the
tree is well I I would think yeah
although there are uh organizations that
have
forests
so you plant a tree in a forest yeah
I I have I'm a member I've become
um
part of a company
that is called a story file
and story file records you with 18
cameras in 3D
a computer records your voice
and the technology is that you can play
this tape of you by pressing a button
and and anybody can ask the image of you
a question and the technology
if you've been interviewed long enough
we'll answer the questions imagine wow
some grandchild or some great great
Williams
you gave her to chat GPT yeah exactly
William shat GPU that's funny
but it would be along those lines yeah
but the technology allows you to ask the
image a question so they foresee that
being in a booth imagine if some of the
greats uh like Beethoven and Einstein
and you were able to say oh it does that
what's the difference what were you
thinking when you did X Y and Z and he
said well I did that too I would fear
that
for example uh Bob Marley The Legend Of
Music yes now that's a strange name to
pick for them well example you're going
to do well because Bob Marley's music
has gone on after he's passed to be
sampled and and made into all of this
aggressive techno Electronics oh I see
what you mean and I just my gut tells me
that if Bob Marley were to be made aware
of the ways in which his music has been
sampled and repurposed that he would be
deeply offended Maybe I'm Wrong well
buddy he spoke a lot of dope right
so hey Bob you know they're going Bang
Bang Bang on your music he goes ordinary
zoom zoom zoom
bam bam bam is not good zoom zoom zoom
is better I mean
saying maybe I'm wrong maybe he wouldn't
be offended at all and maybe it's
perfectly fine because it's his estate
which licenses the music so it's all in
order but I make that example because I
wonder if if if this it sounds like
artificial intelligence that you're
describing to answer the questions it's
going to end up putting words into your
mouth well hang on you that's two
pieces of technology that are separated
one is I spent five days in front of a
camera okay okay uh and the technology
is such that you pay for the length of
time you wish to be interviewed you
could spend the morning at an X number
of dollars or spend you've got a lot of
money you spend five days in front of a
camera and reveal your whole life for
your for your uh
the people that come after you okay uh
so it can only take from that Library
it will take from that Library whereas
the chess where is the artificial
intelligence making things up is not
what you said right okay good so there's
a difference there and a very serious uh
difference because
as we all know there are machines that
can make you sound like somebody else or
have you sound like yourself saying
things you never said right and now
we're almost at the point uh where your
image is uh you you can't tell the
difference between what is not you and
you and so
as we all know the potential of an image
of somebody important saying something
of importance that that person never
said or did or uh we're at War you know
the terrible things are happening
so that's something that we all need to
deal with this other thing is you
uh leaving a testimonial right not
unlike a lot of a lot of people leave a
picture on the tombstone of themselves
of the dead person well this is like
leaving a moving picture because what it
wouldn't be wonderful to go to where
your tree is or if you're uh uh if
you're traditional wisdom uh well
whatever words of uh it wasn't he stupid
he was such a I knew he was stupid look
at what he said there you know so the
truth would would reveal itself
the truth will reveal itself and even if
I don't like the truth I want to know it
and that is why I wear a whoop band now
according to my whoop band I did not
sleep very well last night I'm working
on 11
recovery and that's just a bummer but it
makes sense because it was my first
night on a new tour bus here in the UK
but you know what it tells me what to do
about that it says that I'm overreaching
today because uh you know I'm not
recovered to perform tomorrow I got to
get to bed earlier I need more sleep
than usual because of my higher sleep
debt and strain see that's important
stuff to know that's the truth about
what I need to be doing and my health
monitor man
heart rate variability is low I never
get that and I know because I've got
multiple whoop groups of my buddies I've
always got the highest HRV in the group
but sadly not today at least I know that
though and you can know all kinds of
stuff about what's going on with you if
you get a whoop band too plus if you go
to whoop.com that's
w-h-o-o-p.com and use the promo code
Stevo you're gonna get 10 off at
checkout and a root membership is just
crucial man it's the most sophisticated
Fitness tracking device known to man
you're gonna know about how many
calories you're burning keeping track of
all your activities how oxygenated your
blood is it goes on and on and on and on
and you go to whoop.com to get it with
the promo code Stevo now let's get back
to it but it's it's like
allowing yourself to live a little bit
longer right
that was my whole obsession with the
video camera was that that the videos of
me would outlive me well what what what
was wrong with that nothing was wrong
with that I love it uh
a certain number of your films will live
long after you are you happy with that
do you do you want the your films
because you you you had made films of a
particular style yeah do you want to
watch that to live long after you yeah
here's what my father did yes
um the uh I actually had somebody ask me
a question last night I think there were
there was an interviewer I think they
were kind of trying to get me you know
to to rib me a little bit they said is
stapling your ball sack to your leg
something that you consider wholesome
did you do that yeah I did oh my God
are you serious nightly did that that
lengthened
pull on the muscles I don't think it
lengthened it and and the content just
tighten it
the contacts
I had just been saying that I feel our
jackass movies have a wholesome quality
because the spirit of it is positive and
designed wait a minute
the the jackass movies were positive
yeah and and memorable they were they
were
incredible testimonials to what the
human body can stand and what the mind
can do to overrule the natural
inclination for self-preservation right
that's true
and that to the extent that what we did
is that self-destructive Reckless yeah
dangerous yeah yeah I would use all
those work yeah we are all uh attention
[__] and very uh eager for the
attention and yeah and and uh very very
uh willing participants in what's going
on which makes it permissible to enjoy
watching it because we want all of this
stuff to be happening no no that's
permissible from your point of view from
the observer's point of view holy can
you say [__] on this for sure holy [__]
stapled his balls to his leg yeah how's
he gonna run oh my God he's running you
know how's it gonna how's he gonna [__]
oh my God he's [__]
right and my answer to this guy I said
well
um The Human Experience is uh is is
really a
catch-22 situation we have one instinct
which is to survive yes and one
guarantee which is we won't survive
so we're starting out in a jam and as we
Barrel towards this inevitable Collision
imminent demise our bodies Wilt and
deteriorate so it even if you have a
great life it's gonna suck at some point
luckily for you Bill you've made it 92
years and you're still doing great which
is unbelievable stapled my balls yeah
that's my secret to a long life I said
that's if you have a great life
but a lot of people yeah but you know
you know those are relative terms what's
a great life I mean look I love dogs I
have two I've had dogs all my life
usually two to one to keep the other
company and they're with me like look at
this guy's in hinden is drooped over but
he's so ecstatic this is a girl that's
Wendy so Wendy it's so ecstatic to be by
your side she's got a hip rotation there
that's got to be you know that muscle's
got to be searching now I'm not going to
move because if I move he'll move his
arm around
I I I I I I love what where am I going
with that with animals uh uh so what's a
great life it's a great life like God I
had I had this great dog I suffered
through her death because they they're
10 10 12 years she's gonna you know
she's older now she's got four four five
more years really that's why you get a
tortoise they last a hundreds
so now I've had
a Decades of dogs lives I have lives
that are cherished that's a great life
my part of my life has been with my
animals sure
that's a great life right it could have
been under a tree in in total poverty a
guy living in a under the drawbridge uh
with a plastic tent has his love whether
it's his lady or his guy or or his dog
for sure isn't that a great life for
sure so what's a great life it is a
subjective question I agree peace of
mind but well what I told this
interviewer last night was that a lot of
people don't like their job they might
have health problems that are giving
them considerable stress that maybe not
happy in their marriage and any of those
people with any of those problems I
submit to you that when they're
confronted with video footage of me
stapling my balls to my leg they are not
thinking about their problems and as
such I have made their problems go away
albeit temporarily I agree with all of
that and for that I consider stapling my
balls to be Noble and I have dubbed
myself I've
so I had one experience with uh Johnny
uh Knoxville Knoxville okay so I'm
sitting on a Deus with uh
um Mike oh that it wasn't Knoxville it
was me when I ran into Mike Tyson yes it
was you I broke my nose on Mike Tyson's
fist right I'm gonna described you
something that that uh Mike Tyson and I
looked at each other
like I can't believe
so you're sitting on one side of Mike
I'm sitting the other side of my and
where it was a a roast of some kind and
and I I believe you were in on the
conversation we're talking about all
kinds of the religion and what he's
doing and and the boxing and it was
great I had a great time on the Deus
with him talking
now it's over
thank you very much everyone
Johnny says to
uh
to uh I said to Mike so Mike hold your
fist out yeah places what
I hold your fist out
you mean like this and he puts his fist
out
he goes across the stage and runs into
his fist yeah so we both look at each
other what is going on and he says
it didn't work
let's do it again and Mike says what run
into your fist again
many times
when it was bleeding ah
okay got it oh my nose was about to
break my nose was all the way over here
it was so badly broken and you're on
YouTube yeah do you remember what you
said afterwards the camera it's so funny
like no what did I say
Stevo what the [__]
it's fantastic Stephen what the [__] but
Stevo what the [__] is what everybody
says
is a normal response to that what the
[__] because you there there's a chip
missing
or more kindly you've got an additional
chip okay
you and your crew but some of the crew
have only half that chip because they go
oh geez you mean I get you want me to
throw myself on the cactus
okay you know like I'm going to be
reluctant to do this Steve does it three
or four times right the other guy the
other guys there's more than one to go
oh God it's gonna hurt like hell and
then you have to take tweezes and pluck
all the things
that's crazy it it is and once again
when people what is it tell me what that
is that is um the highest level of
attention seeking
and and it's not that I how you said
that more than once you really mean it
yeah but you're so bright you know
you're good looking you've got great
feet
you could do it you could be you could
be foot commercials I don't know about
that
I I uh you know my my desire for
attention outweighs my need for Comfort
wow and um and and again I I uh quickly
where does that come from uh well you
don't have to be Sigmund Freud to
imagine that a lack of attention and
supervision from my parents plus growing
up in five different countries where I
was always the new kid in school and
always looking for attention yeah and
you got attention by saying hit me not
hit me like at one point I unscrewed a
salt shaker and consumed all the salt in
it to try to impress uh my classmates
did you blow up the next day it was the
water retention
I've learned since then that that was a
particularly bad idea
well a lot of those ideas
for your longevity the fact that you and
I are sitting here now is like
I was looking forward to it to talk to
you about it because it's so unusual
it's
you know
it probably could be likened to the
tradition of monks piercing their nose
and their ears and and putting uh
needles through them and I I think what
they were after was their ability to
control their mind so that the pain
wasn't overwhelming is that what you're
doing you had the guy come over your
house one day and stick the needle
through your hand right didn't you right
did you actually stick that through your
hand yeah
was it a special effects is that that
one you just actually put a needle
through your hand and then you call it
magic
did it hurt it hurt a little bit Yeah it
hurt a little bit so wait a minute does
pain tolerance come into this again it's
uh like if I had uh an extraordinary
tolerance for pain
um then there would be no reaction to to
uh the experience of the pain and what
makes the the jackass movies and a lot
of the things that I do is the reaction
so so feeling the pain is really uh
integral to the art and but the
expression of the feeling of the pain is
also there isn't it yeah I mean you
could scream and faint that wouldn't be
as theatrical as saying oh my God this
hurts I can't tell you I'm going to tell
you how much it hurts as a fire burning
into my head I can't move my fingers
screaming and fainting is also highly
entertaining I think but it's momentary
there's another thing he's dead you know
he ceases to to entertain you right so
you got to stay stay conscious to be
really entertaining he expressed himself
pretty well when he had the beehive on
his dick
yeah
he did he yeah they they actually
strapped the queen bee to my weiner
no come on I missed that one yeah
I got stung about 12 times I did I make
your wiener bigger I didn't um my wiener
got away with it I I took one on the
balls 12 times yeah I got to install
them so would you swell up
nah I I appear to be not allergic to
bees well I was going to say if nothing
happened then it was like a sweet
reminiscence it was it was it was uh it
was what we call a trailer moment
[Laughter]
but but did they fuzz over your weeder
so yeah because it was an R-rated movie
but if it were showed on television
which they are yeah you'd have to fuzz
out they will the very excitement I mean
that's the exact did you get an erection
believe it or not having thousands of
bees on my weiner did not arouse me but
my lady does arouse me and when I take a
Bluetooth tablet and my lady extra
arouses me why because Bluetooth tablets
have the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Cialis except they only cost
a fraction of the price and I can assure
you they are a very good time if you've
ever been thinking about trying a
Bluetooth tablet to learn for yourself
that it's a very good time then man are
you in luck because the listeners with
the Wild Ride podcasts can get an entire
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets
absolutely for free you only pay five
bucks for shipping that is if you go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code Stevo
quickly consult with the medical
provider online I mean a couple minutes
and these Bluetooth tablets are on their
way to you an entire month's supply for
free all you pay is five bucks for
shipping again that is if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo now let's get back to it I did not
I did not get an arrest did it shrink
but I looked pretty good at the moment
you know for you know like how did you
try and get it up I didn't try to get it
up but I I was pretty happy with where I
was in my flaccid State as far as not
being too contracted yeah you think with
like the blood flow going there you'd
get an erection you must have had a good
lawyer to have a a good a good person
I do not disclose it was a it was a it
was a nice warm day
man I'm telling you
one more question or another question
do you anticipate it do you like
it's going to be a B on my weiner that's
going to be that's exciting
I got to give the person who thought of
that a bonus yeah closer to thousands of
bees I found out that it was happening
after I arrived on the set that day the
actual bit had not yet been assigned to
anybody and when I heard about it I said
oh that's all me let me get that one did
anybody fight you on it nobody fought me
on it everybody uh
everybody just let me have it so so
that's a really interesting
motivation Dynamic of attention
people talked about that for sure months
yeah
that one is uh
um I mean you know we're both authors I
wrote a book about
this uh well I wrote a book in which I
discussed this idea of attention and and
how I I I was seeking immortality with
uh with with the permanence of the
documentation of the video camera and I
really broke it down but but like how
how Immortal are we talking I mean like
to to give context
um how many people who lived 300 years
ago are we aware of today how about
about
I I I think it's like a year but how
about five years ago how about
personalities on film or Heroes and wars
and things like that Eddie Murphy Eddie
uh Audi Audi Audi Murphy Audie Murphy is
he the one that's the World War II yeah
Marine German and he got the Medal of
Honor and we've got into western movies
I can't even I'm I'm messing his name up
I think I think is it ottenheimer and
there's a movie coming out about him
with the Oppenheimer bomb Oh Oppenheimer
I don't know no I remember this person's
not that memorable all the number was a
lead scientist of making uh one of the
lead scientists in making the atomic
bomb I think we're proving the point
that that that how ephemeral the fame is
that's the point right right fleeting
and and temporary uh the Great World War
uh the the Civil War generals their
statues are being torn down I mean it no
matter how much metal you put into a a a
statue remembering you it's eventually
melted down and made into bullets or
something right so so what what is
permanent a star on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame or a tree
500 years I think the answer is nothing
is permanent and so you get down to the
basic question of like what like what's
it all about I think I think I know
something
that is more permanent than what we're
talking about that is good deeds yeah
right you do something for somebody that
reverberates and and that person passes
it all and it just continues yeah I I I
agree
um I want to close the loop on on the
tree thing because as I understand it
there are companies that that will uh
sell arrange in Seattle
I think in California something called a
tree pod which is egg-shaped and I don't
even that's exactly right yeah I don't
even think that they that they uh
require cremation I think they actually
fit your body I think there's a law
about your body I'm not quite sure of it
but I think they don't allow
the body itself to be put into the
ground without because like hazardous
waste materials or something that's
exactly right so maybe they gotta but
but if that's what if your ashes it's
different yeah if that's the case or not
but they will actually assign you to a
tree yes like yes the actual tree
absolutely there are I know there are
companies that'll do them I think
there's at least one if not more in
California but I'm sure that as this
thought becomes more popular because I
grasped it from something I read and I
thought that's the way I want to go yeah
and if you do a story file and have a
little camera on your tree somebody come
up and ask you know hey who's treason
that's my dream get the hell up
yeah I think you kind of screw it up by
putting cameras and screens
yeah but you can also like take the
ashes and make it into a diamond and
diamonds are forever
is your song I want to be a tree
available yet my song I want to be a
tree I did uh with uh Ben Folds on the
piano okay uh at a concert I gave at
Kennedy Center and it'll be out uh it's
being uh edited right now and it'll be a
uh available shortly and it'll probably
be call called entitled something like
live at Ken Shatner the guy I'm so
eagerly anticipated it's so much fun I
feel so strongly about that right Robert
sherdo wrote the lyrics I we uh we we
have a team uh Robert Cherno writes the
words I I'm the sort of the idea guy and
editor and Dan Miller of They Might Be
Giants uh is our musical guys so the
three of us have been writing songs we
have an album out there called bill out
there right now which is Gloria it's got
great incredible breathtaking reviews
and then this next album and this uh and
this documentary
uh live at the Kennedy Center will be
all the songs the three of us wrote and
and how long have you been making music
when I was Shooting Star Trek a
well-known uh label account would you
like to make an album oh well I'll look
at them oh sure and so I had a night I
had an idea the idea was to use
traditional
uh great pieces of literature to be or
not to be for example was that signs of
something no okay to be or not to be uh
as a as a example and I recorded music
new music uh original music written to
be or not to be the hamlets so it was a
great segued into the song at the time
was very popular It Was a Very Good Year
uh
and it's a song about the how this older
guys really pause at the age of 24 I did
this the engine 30 I was doing and it
was a very positive life so the two
segments belong to each other
one I'm going to commit suicide to be or
not bad I don't know without gonna and
the others I've had a great life and
music segued into one it was a six
minute cut and when I went to do it uh
one of those cuts on the Johnny Carson
show uh the producer came up to me and
said uh six minutes you can only do
three do you want to do the literature
or do you want to do the song I was well
I'll do the song so the song was uh if I
remember correctly was uh Mr Tambourine
Man a drug song and the literature was
uh something by Cyrano De Pere a speech
by Cyrano given by characters de
Bergerac uh I mean it was Jan's I may
climb to no Great Heights but I will
climb alone
I don't need any help okay sick was into
a drug song I need help a drug song yeah
so so I thought that was really cool so
now I can only do one which one do you
want to do I better do the song now I'm
on the song Tonight Show big druggie big
druggie I'm a drug what the hell is that
and everybody laughed it off and it's
and the thing sank onto the records of
the album sank until uh Ben Folds
discovered it uh in a garage sale we
laugh about it and he and I got together
and we made a great album called has
been and that's been a lauded album when
did Ben discovered at the garage about
20 years later okay wow that's great
um
the uh
I feel like before I'd talk about
the um how much it means to me that uh
that you're 92 and it's just so sharp so
the able of able-bodied because my dad
is 80. and uh the idea of dad
deteriorating mentally or physically
it's just the most uh
it's it's a it's a crippling fear well
of course it is you see your dad as a
young man as a youngster your dad's
all-powerful and all loving it was
everything's your he's your world and
then you be you get older and see him
more as a man and the man himself is
beginning to suffer the ravages of time
and the mind goes the body goes and
suddenly he's no longer Fielding a
kickoff and running the length of the
football field he's saying you know you
do it I'll watch and I'll clapping
the cycle of life is totally natural but
you know what's not natural is all this
darn plastic in the ocean in fact it's
destroying the Earth man and that's why
I drink liquid death from infinitely
recyclable aluminum cans that totally
look like beers except it's just water
dude and man this company just gets
better and better not only are they
saving the world they're hilarious they
took all of the most hateful comments on
their social media page like people
calling them devil worshipers and all
this ridiculous stuff and they made an
album out of these hateful comments it's
called liquid death's Greatest Hits
volume three and dude I love it I love
it Ant-Man you can get 20 off your first
order of the amazing liquid death
apparel all that stuff's hilarious too
if you go to
liquiddeath.com Stevo plus this company
is growing and growing they started out
just sparkling water and still water
then all these flavors of flavored
sparkling water now all of these
hilarious teas the armless Palmer come
on this is the greatest company ever so
represent them go to liquiddeath.com
Devo for 20 off your first order of
liquid death apparel and find all the
drinks on the website as well as on
Amazon Plus at your local retailers this
company is growing growing growing and
that is what we want so rep liquid death
and let's get back to it and uh and
you're seeing what life is all about the
the the deterioration
of
of your body
and many times your mind
I mean I'd like to think that old age
adds wisdom but I'm here to tell you it
doesn't
technology just as much of an idiot at
90 than you are at 20. I'll push back on
that I think that that when you learn
from your mistakes and make the
appropriate adjustments to your
lifestyle that that itself is with so
that that is uh takes into account that
you have the intelligence and the
perception and the resources to correct
a mistake oh geez I made a mistake I
better not do that again as against most
people
oh that happened the car hit me I know
they did right and it uh what what how
many people say no I I didn't make a
mistake right that's true and I think
that that the three of us are very lucky
to be sober alcoholics slash drug
addicts and were you yeah all of us he's
been see I I never did that yeah
Vinnie's been cleaning over for five
years Scott's been clean and sober for
10 years and I've been cleaning sober
for 15 years that's fantastic were you
doing this uh when you weren't cleaning
yeah big time so did the drugs help uh
uh say allay the the pain the there were
some things that
wouldn't have happened were it not for
uh acute intoxication
um those things were not uh part of the
jackass franchise because
um like to appear on camera acutely
intoxicated would not have been the
spirit of Jackass we would oh how
wonderful man it was okay it was okay to
finish up a bit and say now let's go to
the bar yeah and it was okay to to be
hung over and even acknowledge that
you're hungover in a bit it was never
okay to be uh really intoxicated it
diffused the purity of what you yeah
what's your ambition undermined the
wholesome nature of them so you're
telling me jackass number two you
weren't super intoxicated in a lot of
those bits uh jackets number one I was
yeah maybe that applied a little bit
less than jackass number one okay
jackass number two I don't think I was
wait but you put the you mind continuing
on this theme of YouTube
the the attention grabbing
look how much pain I can take
concept
didn't include I'm going to get a lot of
attention to begin with
but then when you saw how the movies and
the and the TV show became so popular
people are my God you got his watches
you can't believe it
then you began to get the attention you
craved and you were able to rationalize
hey
I'm getting I'm doing this and it's
salutary I'm I'm doing good here I'm
taking people's mental uh and maybe even
physical pain away from them momentarily
while they watch mine yeah
that must have occurred to you at some
point oh absolutely not from the
beginning though
[Music]
that wasn't the intention but it turned
out to be that's where I was going but
the uh the intention the motorcycle run
by the the eventual effect yeah yeah I
just wanted to be notable I wanted to be
uh noticed I wanted to be noted I wanted
to be remembered and uh and that was you
know kind of but when did you get it in
your head that what you were doing was
taking temporary re uh pain away from
people I think that came along a little
a little later see I think it was a
rationale later on this is could be you
know
I mean I I'm doing it for my personal
benefit but look what's happening yeah
these people come after me saying God
that was wonderful you just uh for a
moment I forgot my problems and and saw
you yeah there are people who who do say
you got jackass got me through some
tough times there there are people who
uh were serving overseas
really helped us when we were deployed
you know the stuff like that and that's
always meaningful I love that huge but
the reason I brought up my dad and
thankfully
um dad still Sharps attack and and very
very uh able-bodied
uh metaphor isn't it sharpest attack
yeah like
yeah sharpest attack like you sit on
attack oh [__] sharp as a cactus needle
yeah
sharpenser razor sharp is a scalpel uh
he's great and and um my dad was a a
successful businessman uh which is why I
grew up in five different countries and
and uh you know he worked as a uh he was
the president of Pepsi Cola in all of
Brazil when I was six months old no
kidding he went on to become
a high level big tobacco CEO I'm sorry
to hear that and then he uh became the
president of Nabisco International now
I'm happy so he saw soda
um cigarettes and cookies making him the
biggest murderer
a huge drug dealer was she on the was he
on that panel and uh in front of the
government saying no no
our dad was very involved in the with
the lawyers and uh and and how to nimbly
get around just continuing mass murder
uh for sure
um but uh but with that said he really
really uh was in he's an incredibly
genius guy and and uh he's been he's
been retired for a long time but
um the the business component of my
personal career has actually pulled my
father out of retirement
he's basically my business manager at
this point he's uh he handles all my
insurance stuff all my attack stuff and
I really believe that um that that
there's like it's like a muscle the the
the enthusiasm for Life yeah is a muscle
that you gotta and I think that it's
keeping my father uh passionate it's
keeping him it just it's keeping that
fire lit and I think that's keeping him
healthy and giving him longevity and I'm
so so that's wonderful and and I agree
with you and I have
um deliberately
sought
companies that are some of them are
after me some I went after that are
futuristic
[Music]
I'm thinking of one
uh in which
the company has invented a way of
projecting your image very much like
beaming in okay now it requires a
receptacle like telephone booth but we
can project your image into this uh
telephone booth and it's
three-dimensional it's you talking to
the to the audience and the audience
talking to you and you're there in the
telephone booth and if for all intents
and purposes you're there you aren't
it's a projection but it's 3D and it
looks exactly like it and you're
interacting so this is a holograph it's
a a holograph exactly exactly uh
and so that's a company I'm I've become
a member of and I'm going to do that
very thing at a company a large company
gathering in August I'm going to beam in
to a large meeting uh and this is
actually you not Ai and not a
pre-recorded thing no I'll be live
although you can pre-record yourself
right and beam it so you just it's on
film this will not be this will be live
in an actual speech in front of 4 000
people and interacting with the the
Master of Ceremonies or whatever it is
will you be able to see the people yes
there's a camera on the telephone booth
pointing out on the microphone
and of course they can see me and thank
you you're going to get stage fright but
you're not going to be in on a stage
right
it's it's really incredible the
technology and and to the the point
about
um the technology being capable of
putting words and and politicians mouths
during wartime I'm shocked that there
has not already been uh catastrophic
results of this this technology that's
why you have the head of one of the I
think it was chat box uh testified in
front of the government saying we need
regulation yeah and I don't think
regulation is going to do it because
there's always some outlier who's going
to use the technology to their benefit
yeah you can have like a a TV pop-up or
some Vladimir Putin on TV Sam I'm going
to Nuke the United States and you
couldn't tell the difference of him or
not not I'm going to because it's
already said
we're safe in Russia we're live on
YouTube right now oh my God it's
Vladimir Putin's gonna get a speech and
Biden's is my God
send the Rockets the other way and
somebody's done that mischief and
destroyed the world it's sad
we're in the middle we are in the center
of a Maelstrom all of us you guys more
than I because I'm older but
there is this technological Revolution
going on
and there's this global warming
Revolution going on and it's like these
storms that are hitting the East Coast
after one after the other there's this
incredible change that's going on right
now I mean think of it we're in a bloody
truck parked on a street ready to to
reach your audience of several million
I'm sure otherwise I wouldn't have been
doing that
I mean it's bizarre we're talking and
looking and
and all in a on Ventura Boulevard
I mean is it crazy for you because you
were born in the 30s like just to see
how quickly this evolved
you know it crept up uh I did radio in
in Canada I was a part of a Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation both out of
Montreal where I was born Toronto where
I went to live and work so there was a
lot of radio and then TV came in and it
was all cool you know I'm doing stage
work all part of it then
it's uh the live television I go into
New York and suddenly I'm involved in
live television and there's these huge
cameras swooping in on you doing a
close-up and and plays great playwrights
writing for television wow that's great
and then
films started making films and then they
start doing interesting close-ups
they're not model light you needed began
to lessen then you began to shoot film
in Candlelight
Candlelight
that whole film I'm trying to remember
who's it did it in Candlelight uh well
you're saying because before like you
couldn't film something in that low
light no you needed 17 hot Arc lights
and 17 people standing by the ark like
twisting the the carbon so they would
always uh be at that light value I mean
it was so much
so much technological stuff has taken
place and yet
the truth Still Remains and that is
tell an interesting story or get an
interesting personality you would have
been great in I guess not on radio
because you need to see it but in live
television is uh 50 years ago you'd have
been just as great as you are now
because what you do is unique is
attention Gathering
and those truths remain so some of it
slips by the technology technological
stuff slips by it and you got a dog
sleeping on your lap and his eyes are
half open and he's just enjoying it and
that's forever
how are the Hollywood parties in the 50s
and 60s you know different no I never
went I've never seen
I have never seen drugs being used on
the scent in all the years
there might have been guys sniffing and
snorting and drinking back behind a set
I never saw it I never saw anybody maybe
once uh somebody was
out of it but
I never went to a Hollywood party I
never how come
I'm just too busy working I don't know
yeah I just I'm not that isn't me
getting obliterated is not my
personality
I I
was going to college at McGill
University in Montreal so when I got to
University there'd be some kid saying
okay we're going to get some of that
alcohol from the lab and put it in a
grapefruit juice and we'll drink it but
okay and shattered they taste the
grapefruit juice to see if it's got
enough alcohol and I died about three
times I would be the taster a little
boom when I'd be out and the next
morning or get up if it's sick of the
world the room's whirling and I'm
thinking why did I do that about three
times of that negative reinforcement
well that's no fun yeah to be sick the
next morning let alone obliterated and
unconscious the night before
yeah it was it was your life goes out
the window
yeah yes it sure did I'm speaking to the
to the choir yeah
um the the the you can call me Bill
documentary I heard you describe it as
uh as as a for legacy you say you've
been a part of all these different
things all these different shows and and
uh but but it was time to make something
about you so that you could leave that
behind sort of as a message in a bottle
type of yeah in essence that's what I
really I I realize that I'm doing I'm
working harder than I've ever worked for
some reason I don't know why uh I mean I
don't know why I'm working so hard
except that I'm
I'm doing it for my kids
putting the money aside for the kids
everything things are going to be tough
I trying to find ways of protecting them
uh I I don't need the money
yeah got a car you drive the car you you
know you go to a good meal how much
money do you need yeah and I just
I just it moves me so much the way you
described making your documentary and I
um and am pursuing
a a project where I make a documentary
about my dad and his career and my
relationship with him and how it however
what's the driving force what's the
through line
the through line
um
I just think it's the the beauty of our
relationship my um my my dad's career
but I think people there's there's an
awareness that my dad was a successful
corporate executive but uh I think
there's what what's dramatically
interesting about that
well I thought it was interesting when
you used to okay okay I'm glad you're
asking this question I think I've got an
answer
um dad being uh successful the way that
he was had uh ideas about what he wanted
his son to become
um you know it was understood that I
would go to university that I would get
a diploma and that I would be successful
in some kind of career and when I went
to University I could not bring myself
to go to class and I filled out I failed
out as badly as you can and and next
thing you know I say Dad I'm gonna
become a crazy famous stunt man with the
with the video camera and this was the
worst news that my dad had ever heard it
was it was just a bomb and not just my
dad everybody who I told this plan to
felt sorry for me it was pathetic what a
loser I was and I wouldn't give up I
wouldn't give up before I had any
success my dad and initiated a
conversation with me he said son I think
I've done a disservice to you by not
supporting you in this absurd career
path that you've chosen but I see that
you're committed to it and uh and and I
just want you to be the best and pledged
to support me and that put wind in my
sails and and uh and dad and I have been
a partnership so you want to tell a love
story yeah
yeah and and the way that dad started I
think that that would be the conflict
the way the dad struggled with the
direction I was going do you have a
problem with the tobacco industry
um I smoked no yeah you you you're
you're supporting your father by smoking
but I mean there's a there's a dichotomy
isn't there okay goodness your dad did
and and the tobacco industry which was
deliberately lying and harmful okay well
I think that's what's fascinating is
that like you came for money but you
didn't even you rejected at all I mean
you even sat up front with the with your
chauffeur yeah when he when he got
dropped off at school because he was so
embarrassed that he wanted to look like
he was the chauffeur
lie down
dad's [__] dirt poor from like
16 the well when I when I found 26. when
I failed out of the University of Miami
I had nothing to report to my parents
that would have made them proud I wasn't
doing anything that they would have
agreed with and and I had too much pride
I was raised with too much pride to ask
them to bankroll me being a piece of
[__] doing nothing that they wanted me
to do so I uh I I had enough Pride to
struggle on my own and and all right so
what you're telling the story you've got
a couple of stories there that's your
story yep uh of the struggle with being
having a silver spoon and rejecting it
and putting a gun in your mouth as
against a silver spoon
your rejection of that life and and
seeking fame and fortune in this bizarre
stunt life that you have
or it's a story about your father
and his Evolution to say I'll support
you uh uh in in the Life you've chosen
because of my love for you
uh I suppose both could be intertwined
but it lacks a
black drama
to it it's very white and in every
meaning of the word uh
so you're gonna look for a through line
all right that'll hook me to watch it
it's against a pretty boy does a pretty
thing you know yeah and it ends with
stapling I'm glad that I'm glad that
you're that you're pushing back and and
uh and and
challenging me to to make this to find
the compelling elements of it and uh and
I I do love uh the um they I I love when
when you point to the tobacco industry
and it's lies and it's it's greed
um I think that uh that
capitalism greed is uh
so destructive and yes the tobacco
industry is an extreme example of that
but that this bleeds into every the
whole fabric yeah but you know that
that's capitalism gone wrong capitalism
of course is
is the engine behind all this invention
uh
so I mean it's Hollywood it's it's it's
Hollywood with everything it's the web
telescope yeah
ambition for knowledge uh is one aspect
of the goodness of man of the grace of
that right the more you can make the
more good you can do I feel you said
something interesting just a moment ago
that uh you're setting aside money for
your kids because times are going to be
tough
and and what we're seeing with the the
evolution of of the world the the the
wealth Gap the disparity between the
rich the poor the middle class is
disappearing like a hard-working honest
people are being just priced out of of
being able to purchase even a modest
single family home and it it's just that
this wealth disparity has gotten so
severe that it's it's really become what
we would describe as a mega threat along
with the climate change alarm absolutely
you know and um and I have a friend who
I grew up with I've known him since we
were both nine years old his name's
Abdullah he's a devout Muslim and and uh
I I was embarrassed of how big my house
was in school and so I spent all my time
at abdullah's house oh my God and I'd be
praying to in the direction of Mecca
with Abdullah and yeah it was it was
just what happened at his house and it
was my best friend
um Abdullah went on to graduate from
Brown University with a 4.0 and then
went on to places Cornell yeah
but then then he went on to Cornell
Medical School and then he became a
pediatric surgeon at the Mayo Clinic and
actually invented procedures for
operating on unborn babies in the womb
like uh with some kind of coiling
somebody sees just it's unbelievable and
then there's me and what I did and we've
we our paths could not have strain more
differently from each other but we've
always stayed in touch and uh and and
he's just someone I dearly love and we
were playing pool
um in a in a restaurant well over a
decade ago and I explained to Abdullah I
don't want to have kids I don't he says
why he's got he's got like four or five
kids say I don't want to have kids he
says this is why that makes me sad I
said well Abdullah for our parents
getting a University diploma meant
placement in a career of your choosing
for us you know it was helpful but but
no guarantees and for our kids it really
just means nothing but being saddled
with debt and I'm looking at the world
and the dwindling opportunity and I just
don't have the conscience to bring
somebody into this world to struggle and
to be to have everything I just I just
don't don't want to do that and Abdullah
said something to me that I've shared
before but it's so powerful and I love
it so much he said
Steve in Africa with all of the poverty
the the famine the the disease do you
think people are any less happy
and my gut initial reaction is to think
well yeah they're but Abdullah they just
looked me in the eyes and and and I I
got what what he meant was that you can
strip somebody's
um resources from you can you can take
away their their their their their even
their health or take away all their
money you can take it but you cannot
take away somebody's capacity to love
another and that is that capacity to
love is the source of Happiness Okay so
as you're talking a picture that I often
see in front of me formed
and that is this
a mother
with a
cloth over her head
bear arms
child
brown eyes are looking
vacantly
at the mother
flies
are crawling all over the child the
mother's going like this with the Flies
she's starving child starving
and I think of that picture
as a great part of humanity is doing
that while we sit in a truck in our
luxury uh on
on the Ventura Boulevard
I can't believe that that mother is
happy
that child is going to die the mother's
going to die
water resources are drying up all over
the Middle East
you can't tell me that they're happy
if it was a question of I've got the Hut
I've got my children I've got enough
porridge to satisfy everybody and we're
having a nice life that's one thing
but it's gone beyond that yeah
so yeah so I I every time I think about
riches and and comfort them and I think
of this
uh unknown lady
of whom we've all seen so many
documentaries on footage on what's
happening in a
The Bare Bones of Ethiopia or whatever
uh it's not a good life
I I you know um
I I see abdullah's point on on a
spiritual level and and man I I kind of
lean towards towards your perspective I
went ahead and had the vasectomy bill
by stapling your balls
no I had a problem
well stapling oh I put the Staple in the
wrong place
um man I I I'm so honored that to have
this conversation we've we've we've uh
just gone over a yeah yeah we've we've
belligerently neglected to promote your
your current projects
well stars on Mars stars on Mars this is
fun it is it's fun I got the screener
and and I've enjoyed it I've gotten
screeners I haven't seen it I don't know
what the numbers are I don't know what
the reaction is I'm totally the the the
fox has some notified me at all I don't
know whether it's popular whether it's
unpopular but everybody I talked to
seems to have enjoyed it and I had a
kick a real kick doing it both here and
then we went into the Outback of
Australia right is that where that was
oh my God it was awful
I mean it's one thing to be walking
around in dry arid yeah okay but it's
another thing to be attacked by the
Flies the Flies they're so they're so
vicious praised for for moisture that
they attacked their eyes and you go to
say hell and the drug your your mouth
and your ears and and you can't and
that's shooting in the outback yeah
um it doesn't seem from from uh the
episodes I saw that you actually
interact with the cast well I was there
a part of what I did was shot here uh
using some of the footage they were
shooting there then I went there and
interacted so the latter parts of uh
this I don't know how many with 10 or 12
hours that we shot uh the latter hours
I'm I'm involved with them in uh Cooper
PD
500 miles into the Outback I I tell you
what's fascinating about it is the star
power on that show I mean that's
something Ronda Rousey is on there she
is a superstar and a lovely person too
uh uh and uh Natasha Leggero
Marshawn Lynch
William Sherman William Sherman yeah
yeah and then she's a great athlete yeah
yeah and people who are so popular and I
don't know do you know all these popular
people I do I'm I'm aware the the person
I didn't know was the Vanderpump Rules
cast member but that show is so sizzling
hot right now I think that's Mario's
buddy uh nah Tom Sandoval was Mario's
okay this this guy's a different guy
anyway a lot of Firepower there it is
and uh the show's fascinating it's um
it's uh a simulation of what Mar what
Life on Mars and the fact that they
built that they took out to the desert
there is a really good simulation of
what astronauts would need right uh to
live in uh on Mars right and they they
they're they're by the books they
they're dotting the eyes and crossing
the t's of what would be required to
exactly be on Mars now of course they're
not on Mars but it's so uh so faithful
to the science of a colony on Mars that
it's just fascinating and what's even
more fascinating to me is that with the
the fragmentation of the media and how
many eyeballs are diverted to to social
media to the internet to to YouTube to
all this that the streamers taking away
all the the necessity for for uh
traditional television networks how
there there's a viable business in this
being a television show with that much
star power with that much just evident
like
cost to this show how are there are
there that many eyeballs watching
television to justify this this well I I
will find out I mean
it seems that television is uh is is
getting really up there with the the
movie industry as far as just being an
exercise in incredibly high stakes
gambling right
it's uh can I ask you what your favorite
sci-fi movie is did you have like a
favorite Space movie
did you like Interstellar you know they
got the technology has gotten better and
better yeah as can be evidenced by the
Star Treks that that have evolved into
now yeah that's spending 10 million
dollars out an hour and we spend 185
000 hour for me
um so the the technology has gotten
better
uh Star Wars has got great technology JJ
Abrams understood the trick uh to make
it a ride so the movies he made for Star
War uh Star Trek uh were successful
because of the ride
but a great science fiction movie needs
to have a great science fiction
thesis
idea concept
so I I don't know where to go with that
the uh
what's his name did
uh
like water
um
the uh that movie like water yeah that
won an Oscar yeah no that like water no
the the science fiction film
trying to remember
um
it was uh people they lived in the trees
and they've done their jobs
the Avatar movie do you like those well
the technology is
per Perfection
I'm curious about something and then
we'll let you go here
um shortly but um
the
is it true that the the the Star Trek
series in which you start as Captain
Kirk only lasted for three seasons right
so we did 79 79 episodes 79 episodes
quite a bit but
um the uh them canceling it after three
seasons
does that did they go on to think wow we
really screwed up did it become
incredibly popular after it was six
years afterwards they started something
called syndication yeah and that began
the popularity of Star Trek people began
to see it whereas it has been hidden at
uh late in the Friday evening and you
know they just never saw it but
something
that caught the audience's eye that
caught my eye they had made a pilot that
didn't sell got in touch with me when I
played the captain I came to see the
pilot I thought wow that's that's really
interesting I'd like to be a part of
this so something
of the Star Trek
Amelia attracts people and now you got
all these different Star Trek hours in
it just multiply yeah I read that they
wanted it so badly that they're watching
bloopers they're sending airing bloopers
from Star Trek yeah right yeah they made
so we the the editors took
uh you know I'd kid around on the set or
somebody and they would make a Christmas
film for us so without a Christmas party
they'd play bloopers for 20 minutes so
we had two Christmas parties in three
years and then all of a sudden they were
selling it which some of the actors who
didn't get you didn't get paid for
bloopers I'm assuming right that's funny
she's stuck she's like your legs yeah
pull her help her Wendy Yeah Wendy
I I heard you say that your career has
spanned 80 years more more so so that uh
presumably means that you are a child
star I was active when I was six
wow and that was in radio uh that was on
stage actually
yeah it was water yeah I got her some
water
um so six years old tonight I was on
stage and then continued on it's
incredible it's unbelievable
it's absolutely and yet I feel like I'm
looking at this microphone and it's like
an old friend I know I know this bike
except the mics we used were uh
I don't know the Triangular so that you
could fade in and fade uh do you
remember those at all I mean I no no
then there was a microphone that Ben
Folds used that Hitler used oh it had
energy inside it electrical power tubes
inside the microphone for clarity and
all that
um it's it's just incredible
86 years and going and the stars on Mars
is fantastic
you can call me Bill is forthcoming hey
uh there's a wonderful series that's big
hit called The Unexplained uh on uh on
uh
God yeah on
Netflix and
and history it started on History it's
on Netflix it's a big hit uh
then of course there's a watch
the watch for company egard came to me
and said we made a watch some years ago
would you like to try another one I
thought yes I've got a vision and I
describe what I wanted for the the face
they made a beautiful watch so this
watch is coming out called passages and
it'll be out soon and it's uh it's it's
got the web telescope as a second hand
the Earth and the Sun hours and minutes
and on the on the face is the Milky Way
and the bracelet looks like moon rock
wow okay so it should be something
what else have I got the album's
forthcoming
Kennedy Center there's two albums one
live and the other one bill which is on
Spotify and Spotify the uh the books the
books have been oh uh uh there's a book
out there called bold to go uh which has
gotten nice reviews
yeah it's uh it's a prolific career to
say the least well
yeah yeah and I'm working on something
that could be so phenomenal I'm working
on a children's album with my team Rob
Cherno Dan Miller
uh
the interconnection of nature
okay of just briefly for example
elephants in Africa on the on the plains
of Africa no no trees nothing what's on
the planes are termite Mounds
the elephants have an itchy butt they
scratch themselves on the termite Mounds
the Mounds break fall to the ground
there's a little
definition of it from the elephants
walking around it rains that little
definition gathers water the water seeps
in makes it bigger the animals come to
drink water and finally there's a
watering hole they make watering holes
these elephants by accident but it's all
part of the interconnection of nature
yeah we'll have 12 14 songs of the
interconnection of nature for children
along with a children's book Illustrated
with the lyrics and that's cool it's
unbelievable
like like like we've just written a song
you you see in the news the beluga whale
that's a spy whale well I had a harness
it looks like the the Russians were
using it as a spy so we've read the song
about the beluga whale that's a spine
like a James Bond spy and he but his
bulk is a thousand pounds he's a guy
finds it hard to hide this beluga whale
so it's great [__] it's fun that's great
it's it's incredible it's it's been an
absolute honor thank you for sharing in
our creepy van
it's homie now you got to serve uh
grilled steaks or something yeah
um
it's uh yeah I mean it's it's just great
to be able to bring the studio to the
guest oh it's perfect it's a great idea
yeah and uh looks like like Wendy's all
ready
gentlemen thank you so much
thank you Bill yeah I really appreciate
it uh you do one thing for me though
sure all right I want you to run into
this Mike
you break your nose
real quick
well there you have it folks William
Shatner is beyond legendary I means
I love that guy and I loved you for
sticking around to the end of the Wild
Ride podcast man
um what episode was this 167
dude it's crazy it's crazy we got
William Shatner
get the [__] out of here
actually don't get the [__] out of here
stick around to the end every time and
come see me in the UK plus the last leg
of The Bucket List tour in the U.S
September
tomorrow
thanks everybody